I tried to be the guy that knew stuff  didn't work well because there's no  Solutions  it's just they just present one horrible  thing after another that's not true and  then you just watch people go after the  tail they're never the head that's  ridiculous there are many many people in  this world who are better off because  boring people locked in rooms eating  cold pizza at two in the morning with  stale coffee worked on yes drivers  excuse me worked on problems so that  lives could be made better and they were  that was one of the most Vegas longest  sentences I've ever heard in my life  well if you wouldn't interrupt me so  much I could finish what are you talking  about I listen to my whole sentence uh  for example uh  senior poverty used to be 27 and then  people worked very hard to pass social  security and now it's under 10. because  they have government agencies who work  on that are you suspicious at those  stats are